relationships are complicated you know
when you're as good looking at you or me
and I never late to you in this respect
we could have anyone we want I've always
been that way for me really I just
always found like because people to say
that about like kind of being an act or
whatever I just always think it actually
kind of narrows things down but instead
of it's true
they're kind of because one thing you
get all paranoid about everything you
have no idea why people like you or
whatever
haven't also like most people don't they
may think they want to have relationship
with you but if they start having
relations with you they actually realize
like this is not what I want at all it's
like you know you get all the crazies
you can't do anything you basically have
a bit of there's a big imbalance like in
the relationship that's like it's kind
of it's a tough I know I did it that way
you're right I mean it does sort of
narrow daily you can't just go to a
restaurant pick up some girl because you
you could be looking at all kind of
legal problems and people have to get
you the idea other thing too yeah yeah
the woman you're with is like a really
good singer FK twigs and there's a
racial element to that people give I
can't even believe in this day and age
she gets [ __ ] from your fans because
she's a black woman likely he'll write
her nasty things yeah and it's like it
was kind of it's like it's I think it's
just professional trolls will know that
professionals are both yes people they
get so addicted to kind of just wanting
to cause hurt and pain on someone and
it's sort of and it's one of the most
difficult things to know how to how to
confront really because you're just like
I don't know how to I mean it's a
faceless enemy and I don't if someone
came up in the street and said that it's
one thing and that you can you know
you'd know what to do you know what to
say but when it's literally just this
kind of like numb like a little random
name on Instagram some [ __ ] in his
basement and they're probably in a
different country somewhere and it's
like it's just crazy and you kind of and
like it might seem fake to them but it's
definitely like it's real again in your
life and even if you think oh you can
turn it off or whatever it's still like
just to know it's there it's like if you
know that there's like one room in your
house where like if you don't listen up
against the wall you hear everyone
talking [ __ ] about you and then in the
next room like yeah even if you don't go
to that room if but whenever you feel
bad about yourself you're going to go
down there a nice
listening to the whispers I agree with
you I think it is the hardest thing and
as a guy I know we all try to fix things
I know if someone attacks my wife on
Twitter or one of these things you get
crazy cuz you want to go [ __ ] I'm gonna
I'm gonna go protect you from this and
you can't protect anybody from anything
you feel helpless and then if I feel
like you're feeding it afterwards as
well I don't want it I don't want to
yeah I feel like it makes me feel like
less powerful if you if you're trying to
side you know trying to attack try to
make it go away and it gets bigger
yeah it's trying to attack like a
reflection in the water or something
you're just like punching you just look
crazy whereas you know you think the
only way to show some kind of strength
is like this none of this [ __ ] touches
me